thank you so much Simon you know uh I've
read quite a bit about I've read a lot
of your books and I'm sure many of the
audiences we'll keep a few questions at
the end for Simon to talk about um I
like the name of your company uh
optimism you know I was reading your
bio and uh it talks about you being an
unshakable
optimist and you believe in building the
world
together in the context of everything
happening around us a refuge crisis all
over the
world depending on who you ask they
would tell you we are in a recession or
we are not in a
recession Energy prices food prices
International Trade diplomatic ties are
on an alltime low I
mean you know who gets to war for these
kind of the situation we are in m
Jamie Diamond actually said last week
Jamie Diamond actually he spoke about
multiple things he said AI will take to
three days a week then he said we are
living in the most dangerous time in the
world in a few decades R Delio literally
spoke on Monday and said 50% chance that
there's a World War II I want to ask you
are you still a unshakable
Optimist not
anymore uh so I I think we have to be
clear what optimism is uh and I and I
when when I describe myself as an
optimist uh people's immediate reaction
is that I'm naive or blind optimism is
neither I it is not to be confused with
blind positivity everything's fine
everything's good you know or the
obsession with focusing on the things
that are working and ignoring the things
that are broken um in in leadership this
is dangerous we there's a lot of leaders
who think that they have to be positive
all the time so that their teams will be
POS positive even when things around
them are difficult and that actually
backfires to be honest because when
people are struggling and people are
finding it hard to to be positive in the
day and your leader comes in he's like
everything's great it actually makes us
feel worse because we think there's
something wrong with us um optimism uh
is is very realistic uh it allows for
frustration and sadness it can allow for
sadness uh uh difficulty like but it's
the undying belief that the future is
bright so an optimist would say we are
in a dark tunnel um I do not know how
long we're going to be in here and it
will be difficult but I know one thing
for sure if we work together and take
care of each other we will get through
this and we will come out of this
stronger than we went in um and I still
firmly believe that that if we work
together and we find ways through um uh
that we will come out of this stronger
than we went in and I do believe the
future is bright but how do you get
people to believe that I mean if they
start to believe that they will start to
work together
but to get to the point for them to
believe um how do you get them to that
point to believe that the world is the
the future is going to be bright and
therefore they should come together to
fix it I we have to remember that Human
animals are social animals and one of
the disadvantages you know I I just as
an aside um I believe I believe the
world is balanced um I don't believe in
strengths or weaknesses for example um
so you can take company or human beings
when people like what are your strengths
you know what's your biggest weakness
that famous uh uh interview question
well I'm a perfectionist you know
um uh I work too hard um uh I believe
that there's no such thing as strengths
and weaknesses we have characteristics
and we have attributes and in some
contexts there advantages and strength
in some contexts there are weaknesses
and liabilities and what you have to
know is what your your characteristics
and attributes are and you have to know
the context in which they either and
avoid the ones where their liabilities
and try and put yourself in ones where
their uh where their strengths um uh uh
and I think the same is true here we
have to remember that human beings are
social animals and what makes us uh
Happy what makes us live longer what
makes us healthier is human interaction
and over the course of the past you know
couple of decades with the rise of
Technology we've seen a decline in the
human skills we need for this um you
know there's an irony to this which is
cats don't have to work very hard to be
cats they're just good at it uh but it
actually takes a lot of work to be good
at being human and we aren't doing that
work um uh and we can see it just just
take a look at what's happening um in in
with with the the the crisis in in in
Israel and Gaza right now uh uh it used
to be a time where when we read the news
the horrible news we would call a friend
and we would vent our anger or sit in
our sadness and our friend could hold us
our friend could hold space for us while
we went through this process right now
what's happening is we see the news and
then we go online and we vent our anger
or express our sadness in the open for
the world to see right uh and then
what's happening is people are reacting
to our
reactions and do you think the
connectedness is kind of anti
to getting out of the pessimism to an
optimistic world I mean yeah the more
that you feel that someone has your back
the more that you feel in relationship
the more that you feel your colleagues
your co-workers your your leaders see
you as a human being the more at peace
you feel and the more open you are to
allowing uh uh uh the more at peace you
feel that someone will be there for you
and that is what generates optimism it's
the quality of relationships and for all
the benefits of technology and I love
technology
we cannot we cannot
forget uh that we are Legacy animals
living a in a modern world and we have
to do the work to Foster relationship
and great companies do that great
companies do that Simon in the you know
taking on to the the topic of human
connection you spoke about human
Connection in the age of
AI and I actually believe it's more
important now than before y but is AI a
threat to the human
connection again I'll go back to what I
said before it is it is neither a good
thing nor a bad thing it is depends on
what we do with it how we deploy it and
how responsible we are with it can it be
a a a threat to the human condition of
course I think we've we've seen that I
mean if you saw the movie her I mean
that's becoming a real thing where
people will have relationships with an
AI bot but the problem is that AI bot is
having simultaneous relationships with
millions of people so how special are
you um it can but it can make you feel
special we already have words for this
we saw this with Facebook it's called a
parasocial relationship where you have
all of the feelings of like oh my God
I'm in love this person cares about me
but on the other side is nothing um but
at least the ones who don't have those
relationships will feel good because
they at least have somebody to except
for the fact that it's
fake one minor little
detail um that but level plays everybody
is having fake if everybody has fake
relationships at some point it's going
to collapse um you know I
think again there's a hubris that human
beings have which is we think we're
above nature we forget we're a part of
it and at the end of the day um our we
only know what we know and what we don't
know is way vaster and we we are pretty
junk at making predictions I mean let's
be let's be honest all the predictions
of what the internet would be I remember
they were saying that the death of
bricks and mortar meanwhile you know
Amazon's opening stores and you know
uh uh pred not predor what's the one you
rent clothes what's that one Rent the
Runway they're opening stores they have
stores you know because we're forgetting
the very human nature which is we like
we like Gathering and hunting like we
like browsing we actually enjoy it um
anybody who's in retail knows this
that's why they keep moving things
around in the store things are never
exactly where they used to be they move
them because we like to go looking um uh
people in retail know this um uh so I
think we always forget the humanness of
things um and at the end of the day we
We crave relationship we need
relationship I'm going to switch topics
a little bit um you know trust in public
institutions has
fallen um significantly over the last
few years but the trust in business in
comparison to other public institutions
is still the highest yeah I mean there
is something called the edlen trust
barometer which kind of measures this
and business is the only institution
viewed both competent and
ethical uh and everybody has actually
put their own employer as the highest
trust institution to believe in yeah you
think that's going to fade away a little
bit with machines and AI being in the
mix and of course now the bigger
question is how do you build trust in
the age of
AI so let's preface with I'm a cynical
bastard um and I I think we have to be
careful with uh trust barometers because
they're relative you know just because
we don't trust in Government doesn't
mean we love
corporations right it's a relative scale
yeah all it means is our trust in
government and public institutions is so
low we feel good about the business that
that I can't believe that corporations
are number one um so uh it is ironic
that that that uh that people trust in
business more but I think again I think
we have to take it in context I also
think we have to consider how we view
companies these days and and by the way
uh this also puts pressure on companies
which is um if you go back a few decades
our lives were sort of distributed and
where we got all of our all of our our
needs so for example um uh you got your
sense of community from the bowling the
bowling league you got your sense of uh
uh sort of purpose from church you had
we had neighbors that we actually had
bar with our neighbors on the weekends
um and work was a place that um uh you
were loyal to work and work was loyal to
you and you worked until you got your
gold watch and as an aside I will stand
on stages and I will ask a group of
people like you know who knows what I'm
doesn't know what I'm talking about when
when I talk about the gold watch and
like all the young hands have no idea
what I'm talking about like literally
that metaphor is lost on an entire
Generation Um but we would give our
lives and and by the way there was trust
both ways the company would take care of
us and we would take care of them now
over the course of time we've seen the
bowling leagues disappear we've seen a
church attendance Decline and what we're
now asking our companies to do asking
our work to do is we want them to fill
the gaps we need you to now offer me a
sense of purpose we need you to offer me
a sense of community now we need you to
agree with my Politics as well and this
massive pressure on companies to fulfill
all these human needs which um it's not
a good thing or a bad thing it it is a
thing um and so companies have to
respond and so I think the fact that
people find a lot of those things at
work it probably increases the level of
trust so that's one of the one of the
positive
sides so do you do you see that flipping
at some point of time where uh
institutions which are public in nature
should have higher trust than businesses
I would love to believe that we should
trust government more I mean I guess I'm
an idealist I I think you know these
things are cyclical I think world events
will affect them you know after
September 11th we saw public trust
Skyrocket so I mean I don't think it's
fixed I think it'll it'll it'll wax and
wne over the course of
time Simon I'm going to switch gear to a
um very different
topic you wrote about circle of safety
uh in your book Leaders Eat
Last and that was way back in
2013 and I actually think organizational
behavior has changed in the last 10
years um if you had written that book
now would you write it differently on
Circle of safety and do you think it's
very different now than what it was then
uh no I think it's the same book because
the book is the same I'm saying if you
have to write it now yeah yeah yeah it
would be the I mean maybe I'll use the
different examples but it would be the
same conclusion because I wasn't trying
to describe what uh what trust looks
like in the moment I was trying to
understand where trust comes from like
what is trust and when you ask a
question like that necessarily you have
to go backwards and I went back you know
to the beginning of humankind and
anthropology and how we lived and
overlaid the biology of human
decision-making and human trust and the
anthropological necessities of Trust on
a corporate environment and so our need
to feel safe uh to feel psychological
safety in the places we live and work is
a basic biological constant um it it it
it hasn't changed and it won't
change you know another book you wrote
about is um um start with a y yep don't
tell the date of that one that'll make
me feel even
older
um and and that was a fascinating book
um it's about how you want to start with
a y because you know the purpose and
cause and belief of a
company and then you have a unique way
of doing things and therefore you know
the how and of course all of us know
what a what a firm does or what an
organization
does I almost believe you need to add
the who into the mix from the why how
and what because anything you do in a
company today could potentially be done
by humans or could be done by
machines and the Endeavor of humans and
machines we're going to live in a
Endeavor of humans and machines which
means uh the feedback loop with humans
has to check the responsibility of the Y
even if the machine takes decision on on
your
behalf um so in that context I mean
doing responsible AI I almost think the
who plays a important role on which task
is done by who and how do you create the
feedback loop to you know to make sure
that you valid the way so who who is
already built into the system um why is
that underlying purpose cause of belief
why you get out of B in the morning why
your organization exists why should
anyone care how are the values the
actions you take to bring your cause to
life and what are the tangible
manifestations of your actions your
product for example your your your
advertising your public anything I can
see touch or feel even your metrics um
um and in combination those things make
you who you are and when one of those
things is out of balance it's like I
don't know who you are anymore so if
you're only driven by uh by numbers and
you have no sense of purpose people will
lose your identity I don't know what you
stand for right but if all you are is
purpose and you get nothing done then
same thing which is it's a hippie
commune which advances nothing um and
again I won't know what your purpose is
because I can't see you doing anything
in the world so if those three things
are aligned that is who you are that is
that is that is that is exactly what's
supposed to happen um I think your point
about who does the work is an
interesting one and I would because
that's tangible like who physically is
going to do that task I think that fits
on the outside so if you go back to your
your cause and your values those
decisions should um should run through
that filter first and if AI can help
with that filter then then
great you know Simon um thank you for
that one of
the one of the things
the workplaces are grappling with is
four generations of
Workforce um and it has never happened
before in the last 100 years that you
had four generations of Workforce
working at the same time yeah um you
wrote about Millennials I I I mean it
was a Youtube
video um did it have like 14 15 million
hits it had 80 million in the first week
which was 80 80 million in the first
week I remember going it did caught me
by surprise I didn't expect it um I went
up for dinner once with a guy this is
unrelated obviously uh and uh I asked
him what do you do he says I make viral
videos and I said do you mean you make
viral videos and hope they go viral um
uh because that's what happened I mean
it's like I didn't predict this and I
remember going out for dinner and it had
25 million views and when I was done
with dinner it had 30 million views it
was crazy um but yeah it it went very
much controversial video what was that
it was a little controversial as well um
was and
and and that's the reason why it also
had I think a few I think a few
Millennials whose nerves I touched got a
little yeah that's
all I think everybody else is fine with
all the people in the world who are
between 27 and 40 yeah you touch the I
mean you said nice things you said they
don't like instant gratification they're
lazy they have low
self-esteem that's how they've been
described and they're up for
entitlement uh but you equally spoke
about very interesting four
characteristics you said parenting
technology impatience yeah uh and
environment tell us a little bit about
how organizations
can you know that's a sizable part of
organizational work
in fact now the you know the
zenzi I don't know what your view is are
the different to the Millennials I I
actually believe they're different to
the
Millennials um tell us a little bit how
do organizations handle and create an
environment for them to thrive both
zenzes and Millennials sure so
generational differences are not new um
you know we always accuse the older
generations of being stuck in the mud
and you know not willing to change and
we always accuse the young generations
of want to break everything you know and
that they think they know more that
that's old um uh what's new is the
entitlement thing that seems to be
relatively new um and there's a there's
some interesting reasons for it um one
it's a very connected generation
obviously because of the internet and
they actually have more awareness of
what's going on in the world and have
access to unlimited amounts of
information obviously um but if you
think when we started our careers um we
were I think objectively speaking idiots
you know like we came into the workforce
actually knowing nothing right and so we
had no choice but to defer to those who
had more experience so that we could
learn to advance our careers because we
actually knew nothing and we knew we
knew nothing this Young Generation
that's coming in are starting work on
day one with a knowledge of how the uh
how technology Works how personal
branding Works how social media works
and they're actually bringing a skill
set that sometimes those at work don't
have and so I think what it does is
produced it produces sometimes a warped
sense of value when I show up on day one
for work which is I I think I I don't
think you realize what you're getting
here um and sometimes blinds them to the
fact that that though those things are
true I also need you to learn all these
things and you have no life experience
yet um and so I think that the way we
interpret that is entitlement but what
we also see is that when you when you
bring that young people are bringing the
sense of apparent self-confidence
uh to the workforce learning very
quickly that um work doesn't work the
same way as school which doesn't work
the same way as your parents taking care
of everything for you which you don't
which doesn't work the same way we may
not need those skills today we need
other skills that what you find is that
it can be quite traumatic um um and
you'll find that a lot of the
self-confidence that they uh uh show is
actually false and it's actually a very
insecure generation that has that
struggled with coping mechanisms um and
we're seeing that in Rises of anxiety
depression you know uh and unfortunately
suicides as well um uh and lacking those
human skills that we talked about before
so necessary for people to feel
confident in work so I think all that is
required quite frankly um is empathy and
though it would be nice to demand that
they have empathy for us that we
actually have gone through a little bit
and have seen a few things in the world
that's less likely to happen and we're
supposed to be the older experienced
ones so I think we have to lead we have
to show empathy that doesn't mean agree
that doesn't mean that we can't hold
them accountable but we have to learn to
try and understand the life that they
have grown up in which is different than
the life we grew up in and that affects
their worldview and their behavior so I
think when you talk about the millennial
video yes there was some people who were
a little pissed off and they would say
things like I know many Millennials who
aren't like that of course um uh but
what I found was the opposite which is
the huge huge number of young people who
came to me and said thank you you're
helping me understand why I'm struggling
that there are other that there are
other circumstances in the world that
are affecting me um in other words what
it was was an expression of empathy
which is let me try and understand why
you why people keep asking me why you're
impossible to lead because that's where
that that that video was born from 100%
of the meetings I had 100% of the
speeches that I gave invariably the
first question was I'm struggling to
lead my Millennials why are they such an
unleadable generation and so I just went
on the journey absolutely I think that
was that was so well said I
mean uh knowing what the Millennials
need and setting up an environment for
supporting them and therefore get
getting the best out of them I think was
was
important you know just on the topic of
uh uh knowing them you know one of the
things I'm personally very passionate
about
is um asking for
help uh vulnerability is not a Str is
not a weakness it is a
strength
um it is you know in some ways it's
easier for me as a CEO of a company to
be vulnerable because I have no
insecurity but to build a culture of
vulnerability where everybody can ask
for help yeah uh I think is a huge
strength tell us how organizations can
build culture to thrive in vulnerability
I mean it is such a unique opportunity
for Enterprises to take a lead yeah and
make
vulnerability a virtue a strength and um
asking help is a strength and not a
weakness yeah well Amen to that um uh I
think there's a few things number one we
have to define the term you know I think
the word vulnerability scares a lot of
people especially in business business
uh nobody wants to be vulnerable nobody
wants to share their weaknesses why
would I do that it'll hurt my
promotability I I don't want to be
humiliated you know um so I think first
and foremost we have to Define what it
means this is why I like terms like
psychological safety or circle of safety
that we have to build circus of safety
and I don't need to use the word
vulnerable because then I end up having
a semantic debate with someone um so
when we talk about being in a circle of
safety or feeling psychological safety
uh or being vulnerable what that means
is and I think we have to be declarative
about what it means uh by the way of
example what it means is that I can
raise my hand and say I made a mistake
or I don't understand or I don't think I
have enough training to do the job
you're asking me to do or I need help
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution in fact I can say these
things with absolute
confidence um that someone will rush in
to support me whether it's my colleagues
or my leader and we've all been on a
team where we had that unfortunately
we've also all been on a team where
you'll never admit a mistake you'll
never admit any Gap in intelligence or
something you don't know you'll never
admit you don't have enough training
you'll never ask for help because it
will get you humiliated or affect your
promotability um uh and so if we if we
can talk about the fact that we've all
built like that and we'd rather work in
situations like this then we have to
reward that behavior one we have to we
have to we have to um set as an example
so to your point you know um when you uh
Express that you don't know something
you ask for help um that's a good thing
um also I think people make a big
mistake where uh expressing
vulnerability is not the same as being
vulnerable expressing weakness is not
the same as being weak so for example if
you sat in a meeting and you
went uh I don't I don't understand this
um I need somebody to explain this to me
um I don't I don't know this right
there's no way you're inspiring
confidence in your company um but if if
you simply own it like hey I don't
understand a single word of this deck if
somebody can please just explain it to
me because I'm the complete idiot and I
don't understand any of this text stuff
that would be really helpful and if you
just say it with confidence if you own
it it's the confidence that's inspiring
not the expression of the weakness um so
I think if you're confident in your
weakness um and it you serves that
example it allows others to do the same
also rewarding the behavior in other
words when somebody asks for help
recognize point it out and say Yes more
of that please um uh because I think the
incentive structures and re structures
um affect people's behavior as well you
know I'm going to ask you um a question
which kind of just came into my mind
and I've never found a good answer for
this and I'm hoping you can performance
appraisal systems in every company I
worked for and every client I've spoken
to have been the most controversial yeah
and the most um debated topic yeah and
they never put vulnerable on the top
yeah you know if you write these are the
things I don't know your performance
appr is going to be the
lowest tell us what you believe would be
the best performance appraisal system
just a philosophy yeah in an Enterprise
I mean it's you know it wasn't on my
script I was just trying to think about
building something extraordinary for
cognizant and I've never found one and
I'm quite sure many in the audience will
agree that it was it's a it's the most
most
talked topic yeah the person you are
appraising always thinks that they've
done better than what you think yeah and
um you never
agree uh a small percentage agree with
you
because you've rated them high
sure I mean you're not wrong the tell us
is there a philosophy you believe the
world is not tested which yeah somebody
like you should you know y so so I think
what we the failing is we're looking for
Silver Bullet we're looking for the
evaluation that gets everything and the
reality is there's multiple things we're
evaluating usually what we're evaluating
is the stuff that's easy to measure
metrics right we measure someone's
output just because it's easy to measure
and just as an as side um you know this
influenced heavily my my thinking on the
topic um the Navy Seals uh which are not
far from here in Coronado um uh the Navy
Seals uh within the Navy Seals is a more
Elite group called SEAL Team Six which
many of us are familiar with um and I
had the opportunity to uh spend some
time with the head of training for seal
te 6 and I asked him a very simple
question which is how do you choose from
the Navy Seals who gos to be on SEAL
Team Six because they're all
amazing and he drew uh a a chart uh he
drew a graph xyx AIS and on the vertical
axis he wrote the word performance and
on the horizontal axis he wrote the word
trust and the way they Define those
terms performance is defined as how good
are you at your job so I think most of
us are familiar with that and trust is
defined what kind of person are you
what's your character right clearly
nobody wants this person the low perform
of low Trust on their team obviously
clearly everybody wants this person the
high perform of high Trust on their team
what they discovered is that this person
over here the high performer of low
trust is a toxic team member and they
would rather have a medium performer of
high trust sometimes even a low
performer of high trust it's a relative
scale over the high performer of low
trust right now if you look at it in a
corporate context we have a million
metrics to measure someone's output to
measure performance and we have
negligible to no metrics to measure
someone's character or trustworthiness
and so what we have is a lot of toxic
team members whose output is so strong
that we end up promoting them into being
toxic leaders right and so it's not that
measuring the performance or the output
is wrong that's totally fine it's that
that it's unbalanced we need something
to balance it off so what are we adding
to that um I'm a huge fan of 360s quite
frankly I think the way we do 360s is
usually flawed though um the way we do
360s is we don't put them in anybody's
file and we don't use them as a gauge of
promotion we use it as a as a learning
tool and I want to see that your 360
improves over time it's the growth that
I want to see and by the way if you're
growing your teammates like you more and
your output is better as is the team's
output um the way we do it and it's a
way it's not the way but we've tinkered
with it and we like it um is uh you take
the group of people you work with um uh
so your core team so it has nothing to
do with you know just Engineers or just
market like if you have regular
interaction your team um and each person
fills out a form very simple what are
your three biggest weakness what are
three specific examples of your biggest
weaknesses or areas that you believe you
need the most Improvement you have to
write three specific things and then
what are the three specific examples of
the areas that you've grown the most or
your natural strengths and you put three
specific examples we collate them we
give them around and then we sit in a
meeting and each person one by one has
to read out their their weaknesses and
the rest of us get to add to the
list and you don't get to say anything
other than thank you and we give a
little Preamble that starts off that
says um these feedback sessions are to
benefit you we care about you we want to
see you grow as a human being we want to
see you grow as a team member um and the
people in this room would rather not do
this exercise because the stuff they
want to tell you is really uncomfortable
for them to tell you but they're going
to muster the courage to do it because
they care about you so say thank you if
you disagree with something then just
put it aside and brush it away it's fine
if it triggers you if it makes you angry
it's probably
true uh and so the only person who's
allowed to record it is the person who's
getting feedback if they want it for
note taking later um and you do your
biggest three you do this in your form
you said we do these yeah we uh you do
your three weaknesses and then anybody
can add to the list and you can just say
thank you uh and if you go thank you we
shut that down pretty
quickly uh and then the cool part is you
do your three strength and anyone can
add to that list and what you discover
is that you do have blind spots but you
also discover that you have a positive
impact in people's lives that you didn't
even realize you had and it's it's
pretty magical the tears that happen
usually happen with the Positive stuff
um it's really hard to do it the first
time because it is a vulnerable
environment but um over the course of
time it gets easier and people start
really enjoying them um and there's
variations Depending on time some we've
also changed it where you do it and then
you invite three people to come and do
it with you uh just make scheduling
easier but yeah we really like those um
so we we we're constantly looking for
ways to keep the
the the quantitative and the qualitative
a little more
balanced s I'm going to add one quick
comment uh ask you to comment on it I'm
going to say something which is um again
an area where I've worked deeply on but
then I'm going to open open it up for
Q&A you know
um one of the things uh I always feel
inspired about the new discontinuity
coming out with AI is you know
Technologies of the past have created a
divide I mean look at the United States
uh we have 8 million open
jobs there are only 5 million humans
available for those
jobs and there are 4 million people
every month leaving
jobs because they don't see upward
social mobility in the
jobs uh these are people who are doing
20 plus dollars an hour job all their
life so they're fed up they don't see
the American dream so they just walk
they just walk away from one job to the
other so these are the 4 million 4
million jobs a month is onethird of the
US Workforce they just leave jobs I
think we have this biggest discontinuity
of AI coming into picture it will take
away jobs of the past it will create
upward social mobility in jobs because
you can take the path up because uh
those jobs would be done by machines so
somebody doesn't need to do it so I'm
very very optimistic about the fact that
that upward social Mobility is a
lifetime opportunity for us I don't know
whether you had any comment on it and I
think the societal divide which was you
know in many ways done by digital
Technologies including our education
system I mean you know education is the
biggest barrier for good jobs and
education has become so expensive I mean
it's 200% increase in education cost of
Education in the last 20 years so I'm
very very hopeful that um we're going to
see this opportunity a unique
opportunity to bridge that divide I
don't know whether you had any
comments
um
so I think one of the problems that the
that the industry has is narrative and
it's very common when Engineers or
scientists or mathematicians are
responsible for
messaging um they're not good at it and
we probably going to now have more
Anthropologist sociologists you and I
spoke yesterday in the mix of AI because
if machines are going to do the problem
solving the new human endeavor is going
to be finding new problems sure which
will be which will need a different
cognitive diversity for sure but we're
still agreed um but there's still some
somebody who needs to be responsible for
the storytelling and the marketing of
whatever it is and you you just you know
um climate change is a good one one of
the mistakes of climate change is we
allowed the scientists to do the
messaging and they called it global
warming and people like global warming
this is the coldest winter we've ever
had you know and we screwed up the
messaging for so long that it created um
uh so so created conflict it created
conflict um another one that's had a
complete failure of messaging is crypto
and and and and the blockchain like most
people have no idea what you're talking
about and all it does and and when
people don't understand fear is always
the reaction um and I think AI is now
the next one which is I think there's a
an underlying messaging problem and
there's a lack of empathy in how we're
messaging that you know all these jobs
can be replaced like just as an analogy
you know it's like well-intended
uh climate change people who come into a
town in Ohio and say okay all you coal
miners this needs to be
solar and what they're forgetting is
that this coal miner his father was a
coal miner and his father's father was a
coal miner and all I know is coal mining
and that's how I raise my family and
that's how I pay my bills and you're
coming in and telling me that I have to
that you're replacing it so that I can
have more upward Mobility or something
like that and what I all I can hear is
what am I going to do and I think that
all of the the purveyors of good
technology and and good intent have to
be empathetic for the people in the
receiving and of of these messages and
understanding the situations they're in
and then you'll have uh less push back
but I I you know um it's all fine and
good to talk about the Bright Futures
but we have to consider the people who
are on the receiving end of it so well
said so let me open it up for any of you
to ask questions to Simon
there's one here
yeah go ahead I can I can shout out the
question sure go
ahead I I think thank you this has been
going around ways saying that we should
do it we should not do it but I'll can
we bring the house lights up please
that's possible better yeah no no I can
see it thank you yeah now so my point is
that why don't we talk about the culture
of growth growth in a year rather than
performance as an individual we always
talk about how you did in your job but
if we say hey what's your journey you're
going to work in your life for 30 40 20
years how where do you want to be at the
end of retirement are you adding any
value to your journey and measure that
as one of the Ved in performing because
if you're not doing right by yourself
you can't do right by companies right so
you're I think philosophically you're
100% right I think one of the challenges
is that most companies and we've seen
this over the course of the past few
decades most companies don't have the
patience for their people to grow right
so uh this is going this is Jack Welch
Milton Milton Friedman nonsense which is
companies that become shorter term more
quarterly driven or at best annually
driven um and I don't have patience for
to wait and help you on your growth
journey I need my growth and you did my
my numbers um uh it reminds me Gary uh
uh Ridge he used to be the CEO of uh um
WD40 also a relatively Local Company um
he was on an analyst call and the
analyst said Gary you missed your
numbers and he goes no my numbers are
fine I missed your
numbers
um
uh but to Gary's credit he has a company
that invests in like if you're on a
leadership track they they teach you how
to be a coach they teach you coaching
and they've invested in their people and
they understand that people's
performances don't always match the
arbitrary numbers of the arbitrary dates
of running our companies and he has the
institutional patience to allow someone
to go on a growth Journey with their ups
and downs even if it means that he has
to suffer short term because he
recognizes that over the long term he
will benefit which by the way they have
it's a very very high performing
organization so I think not until the
incentive structures and the intentions
of the company align with the desire for
our people to actually grow um because
we you mean we talk about uh reviews we
don't this is the problem with annual
reviews right I'm not actually reviewing
your year I'm reviewing the past two
months that I can remember and the past
two months sucked even though the P the
previous 10 months were
amazing right and so this is why I like
quarterly or at least semiannual reviews
at least then I can see growth and I
will reward growth more than absolute so
somebody who's High performer High
performer High performer is actually
less valuable to me than somebody who's
demonstrating some sort of growth
because you may be a high performer but
I but everybody hates working with you
right so are you demonstrating some sort
of growth somewhere even if it's not at
a performance and companies aren't
equipped nor are they patient for it I
would love to see it yes yes yes more of
that
think I think we but I think it starts
with us as indidual Leaders right if we
create that culture and a pod if we hold
our leaders responsible to grow their
team members it would work better for
the companies it of course yes human
beings are responsible for setting the
cultures of organization Simon
Yesa okay I was told it's my turn yes
yes yes it's all good all right what
I've learned is if you have the
microphone I have the microphone so I
have I get to ask the question so first
up big fan of yours thank so I get your
daily notes to inspire and I'm read one
of those um says chaos is needed for
Innovation yes structure makes those
ideas useful true now in today's you
know age of AI Enterprises need a good
balance of both yes chaos and structure
yes very hard to do for large companies
since youve you know work with many
Global firms have you seen good examples
of companies that are able to balance
and Foster a culture of chaos and
Innovation if so like what are some of
the you know uh success criterias to
doing that so they're not Apples to
Apples meaning you can't live in chaos
all the time right that would be in that
would be unsustainable but you can't
live in uh strict structure all the time
because what you get is government
bureaucracy right which is and my
definition of bureaucracy or a
bureaucrat is someone who doesn't care
right um and so you can't have that
either because it'll kill Innovation and
Status Quo will will will Thrive um and
so what you want is pockets of it and so
you allow for spaces for chaos in other
words whether it's a project that you're
working on or if there's something new
happening you put it outside of the
corporate structure right um and uh uh
and you take it out of the bureaucracy
and you allow them to play and break
things also I think we reward sometimes
we we want to reward Behavior like
initiative but very often we only reward
output performance I'll give you one
simple example um so I was young in my
career I worked for a large Ad Agency a
large marketing firm and we had a big
new business pitch in the New Year this
was December and uh what was traditional
is all the senior Executives would do
the business pitch but it was Christmas
time so they all went on their vacations
and me and one other Junior person were
left back at the office and they told us
prepare the War Room uh for when they
get back so they can do the pitch which
basically means hang the research on the
walls Well that took an hour um and we
still had a week and so we decided to do
the pitch ourselves which is we went
through all the research we went we comb
through it we found some insights and we
wrote the deck we wrote the pitch deck
and when the executives came back we
presented our work and they used Our
Deck in the pitch which was amazing they
actually used our strategy and we lost
the business we didn't win the pitch and
I got a huge promotion my boss promoted
me two levels up I skipped a level
because he wasn't rewarding
my performance he was rewarding my
behavior because he saw the initiative
that I took and he wanted more of that
so I think uh that's a a large part of
it as well if you want Innovation you
have to reward the kinds of behavior
that begets Innovation but if we only
reward output all you're going to get is
people taking safe roads because they
want the output so I think you have to
you have to recognize the reward the
kind of behaviors that you
want thank you for taking my question
there is a conflict in the organization
where leaders who have been there have
had their own path and acceleration of
career and then you have these young
employees who come in and perform better
and their path to progression is much
faster than the leaders yeah that they
are part of how do you balance that as
an
organization right so um this is so
first and foremost I think I think a lot
of leaders don't know their job is right
um and I mean that seriously um when
we're very Junior in our careers our
companies give us tons of training to do
our jobs so that we'll be good at our
jobs obviously and some of us even get
Advanced degrees so that we'll be good
at our jobs and if you're good at your
job you get promoted to a position where
you're now responsible for the people
who do the job you used to do but we
give you no education on how to lead so
we just expect people to know how to
lead and give them no education I I
wouldn't go see a doctor who's had no
education why would I follow a leader
who's had no education and so what
happens is is um because you've given me
no you haven't even given me a
definition of what a leader is you just
told me I'm in charge well that just
makes you an authority not a leader
leadership is the awesome responsibility
to see those around us rise your job is
no longer to do the job your job is to
see those around you be better at the
job than you were based on all that
amazing experience you had it's a
completely different skill set and so
what you find is a lot people who are
insecure so they're going to either
micromanage or tell you what to do
because I actually do know how to do
your job better it's what got me
promoted um and we're very uncomfortable
with the fact that somebody might not
like I had to do it that way you're
going to have to do it that I had to do
my five years you're there's no way
you're going to go faster if I've got
somebody who's smart and talented going
faster than me I want to Foster that
what makes me the leader is that I'm
going to build the best team around me
and the reason they'll follow me and
they're not going to try and uh stab me
in the back is because they see me
offering that grow grow they see me
providing that Circle of safety they see
me offering them uh an ear for them when
they're when they're struggling or when
they need help they I'm regulating when
to jump in and help and when to let them
figure it out themselves and they know
like a parent that I'm always there to
support uh and we aren't a telling
leaders what their role is which is to
lead people and two we're not educating
leaders how to lead and so we're going
to get we're going to get leaders who
are going to stifle br young minds
because of our own
insecurities we're all guilty of it
we're all guilty of it various
times we're running out of time one last
compelling question anybody has to some
of my favorite leaders are the ones who
be like dude these guys are so much
smarter than me I don't even understand
this world but I'm going to do
everything I can to see that every
single one of them is a rock star you
know those are my favorite I love
those
hey
Simon as you had shared the you know the
need for connectedness yeah and for
humans to come together at work and then
the whole story about Millennials and
genz acquiring that you know mentorship
the connectiveness the insecurity and
now with AI as well taking away some of
the lower end roles where people get
training and how to work together this
whole work from home and work from
Office Tobit yeah um you know we have
the whole Spectrum depending on
companies going from one extreme to The
Other Extreme and between where do you
stand and how do you see that kind of
playing out you know yeah so I think of
it a little differently um most of these
things we think of these things
selfishly this is where I want to work
right and I think of all of these things
of Acts of service so first of all we we
all know that the value of this event is
not what's ever happening on the stage
as fun as it may be the values of of the
event is this is that you're seeing
friends that you haven't seen in a while
you're meeting new people you're going
to talk to people at at at meal time
you're going to stand next to them on
the buffet and you're going to create
friendships where you can actually call
people like hey I'm going through this
thing what do you like it's this that
makes these events match because there's
not a single thing we're doing on the
stage that you couldn't see online so
why' you show up because you want this
right and I'm a little I have a
different point of view when I talk
about it as an act of service so for
example we know um that when you go to
an online
Workforce we for let me take a step back
we know that in-person work really
favored the extrovert we know that right
and we know that a lot of introverts
suffered at work and then when we all
was sent home the introverts were like
this is the best right and all the
extroverts really suffered and so when
we're saying hey everybody come to back
to work all the introverts are going
nope no
no I I work better
at home right and the answer is great
except for the fact that there's other
people here as well and you have to do
it as an active service which is yes I
do work better at home but I'm going to
come to the office now and then because
I know that it's the right thing to do
for those who work differently from me
than me and the extroverts have to say I
know that I want everybody to come back
to work because I like it but I
recognize that some people need space to
get their work done separately and so
I'm going to allow for flexibility at
work and so I think an act of service to
each other we all have to let go a
little bit of what we want there's the
combined problem of young people who
started their careers or early in their
careers tasted work from home and they
think it's the world's greatest thing
except for the fact that they're some
they're suffering serious mental fitness
challenges I don't use the term mental
health I don't like the term mental
health because mental health sounds like
a standard that you have to reach and
most of us are feeling like you either
have it or you don't I believe in mental
Fitness fness which is something you
have to constantly work on and they're
suffering serious mental fitness
challenges right and the anxiety is is
getting worse they come to work they
freak out and they say you see I can't
ever come to work not failing to
recognize that it's the being at home
that's creating the anxiety and so I do
think that we have to find mechanisms to
bring people back to work or spend time
with each other do plenty of offsites
whatever it is um because I think 100%
distributed work um is bad for people
um so but I do think of it as an active
as an AC of service I think that we have
to let go a little bit of what we want
for the good of others and for the good
of the team thank you so much Simon what
a wonderful conversation Round of
Applause for Simon thank you so much
really appreciate thanks so much